let me show you how to add cloud
endpoints to an existing App Engine
flexible environment application
first of all let's write running the
application locally it is a simple like
a server raining go so we can run it
with go run now we can verify that
everything works correctly sending a
post request with curl to the plot
application we first configure the
project I ve on G cloud and then we run
a deploy g-cloud app deploy the AE
deploy part is needed only for grow
applications after a short period of
time the application is deployed and we
can test it again using curl great let's
add some cloud endpoints now we will
need an open API specification of our
API in our case it's a very simple one
one single path that replies to post
request with the same message it
receives we can now deploy that
specification to Cloud endpoints with
these Jake lock command as a result we
will receive a Cloud endpoints name and
a configuration ad we now add those two
values to our app the demo and redeploy
application open API is an open standard
which means all the tools developed for
open API are now available for you to
use with Cloud endpoints for instance if
you get your specification and put it in
editor swagger dot IO you can see the
odd jury discrimination which is
incredibly useful for your developers
and also you can even run the
application directly here by saying
hello running that request and getting
the response great right now that we
have deployed our application and the
corresponding open API specification we
get to enjoy monitoring and logging we
can fix on traffic and see how the
graphics react to it or go see how the
logs appear in real time ok one last
thing let's secure our API so only calls
with an API key will be authorized we do
not need to change our code just to add
a security definition on our open API
specification and redeploy let's test it
with curl now without the API key our
request is rejected but without the
correct API key everything works fine so
there you go with a simple open API
specification and Cloud endpoints we get
monitoring logging and authentication
and the possibility of using all the
tools that already exist for the open
API